scp-096 versus scp-204  they say that scp-096 always catches its  prey but could the strength of the  protector finally stop it at the door  let's find out  scp-096 is a relentless and almost  indestructible killing machine that  doesn't even leave traces of its victims  left nothing seems to be able to even  slow it down  scp-204 is a cloud of deadly  self-replicating nanites that recharge  by feeding on living flesh are able to  condense into a powerful physical form  and will do anything to protect the  child they are assigned to however we  think 096 would still narrowly win this  one unlike 096 204's condensed form is  vulnerable to conventional damage which  096 can dish out in spades and 096 would  likely regenerate flesh faster than 204  could reliably eat it the protector's  host child may sadly be doomed on this  one